che cosa straordinaria avere qui degli
esperti di musica come esperti di musica
e sì perché ognuno di noi e musica
se riuscirò a farmi andare a casa oggi
avendo questa consapevolezza che la
musica siamo noi gli esseri umani
sarà un grandissimo risultato
c'è un problema infatti nel linguaggio
perché si dice spesso che per la musica
bisogna essere portati intendendo con
questo che bisogna avere un talento
particolare io invece leggo questa frase
in un altro modo essere portati vuol
dire che c'è qualcuno che ti deve
portare alla musica ed è per questo che
io ci sono qui ho questa lezione di fare
in modo che voi prendiate consapevolezza
del fatto di essere la musica qualche
anno fa avevo letto un libro che si
chiamava disegnare con la parte destra
del cervello di betty edwards molto
interessante a un certo punto c'era un
piccolo raccontino in cui si diceva che
il cervello è diviso in due parti la
parte sinistra che è quella nazionale e
che consente al navigatore con sé stante
bussola carte nautiche
spostandosi in isole che stanno a volte
a 2.000 chilometri una dall'altra
nell'oceano pacifico di raggiungere
l'altra isola con un pensiero lineare o
verticale quello della parte sinistra
del cervello
dall'altra c'è invece il abitante
di queste isole che per andare nella
morisot la vicina a 2.000 chilometri che
cosa necessità di fare non ha a
disposizione se stanti non a
disposizione bus ma all'intuizione e
prende altre informazioni quelle che
passano per la parte destra del cervello
lui
ecco che cosa c'è di attinente con la
musica ed è per questo che dico che noi
siamo la musica perché noi siamo
esattamente strutturati per fare della
musica lui intuisce dove l'altra isola
poi si avvarrà di qualche aiuto di
percorso
l'acqua l'odore delle diverse situazioni
in cui si trova navigando guarda in
qualche modo le stelle e arriva anche
lui dall'altra parte che cosa ci
racconta tutto questo ci dice che
bisogna trovare non una separazione ma
una interazione fra queste due parti che
animano il nostro cervello quella che ci
costituisce pienamente certo come
musicista c'è un problema il problema è
che quando qualcuno mi chiede e lei che
lavoro fa e il musicista non ho mai
intendevo proprio come lavoro ecco come
se fare il musicista non fosse un lavoro
in realtà è una specializzazione umana
straordina
e quello qui vorrei arrivare oggi il
messaggio importante che vorrei che
passasse dentro di voi e riappropriati
del tuo essere musicista e in che modo
scopriamo di essere musicisti perché
abbiamo delle modalità di esistenza
quello che io chiamo il kit di
sopravvivenza per stare in questo mondo
fenomenico che sono assolutamente
musicali pensate ad esempio a questa
scena familiare che prende forse a un
divorzio mario porta fuori l'immondizia
mario porta fuori l'immondizia mario
porta fuori l'immondizia ma io vado io e
mario non ascoltava la moglie perché la
moglie ha commesso un errore non è stata
musicale nel dirgli di portare fuori
immondizia
quando io ma non mi ascolti devo
rimanere 9 50 mila volte nomadi o
semplicemente concentrato a fare qualche
cosa e sta con la parte destra del
cervello assolutamente occupato ma se
lei avesse preso consapevolezza del suo
essere musicale cosa avrebbe fatto
quello che fa ogni musicista quando
compone un brano di musica avrebbe
ordine
le ripetizioni mario porta fuori
l'immondizia mario porta fuori
l'immondizia state sicuri che mario ha
già preso il pacchetto e lo sta portando
fuori non c'è bisogno di una terza volta
perché perché la ripetizione orientata e
la rappresentazione di quello che noi
facciamo nell'esistenza quando noi
ripetiamo qualche posa questo ci
caratterizza con due possibilità o
ripetiamo per affermare sempre di più o
ripetiamo per attenuare un altro libro
interessante era stato il pensiero
laterale che è proprio una possibilità
da sondare come funziona la parte destra
del cervello
molti di voi adesso si staranno
chiedendo che cosa c'entra questo con la
musica
ma che cosa vi aspettavate che io
venissi qui a suonarvi qualche cosa o a
descrivervi come funziona una sinfonia
ma se il mio obiettivo è quello di
dimostrare che vuole siete la musica
siamo in casa stiamo parlando fra di noi
di qualche cosa che ci caratterizza che
cosa dice questo pensiero laterale che
un conto è stare nella linearità e
pensare che le cose sono una dopo
l'altra
quindi è il tempo fisico che scorre
inesorabile in un brano di musica
pensate che l'ambizione è quella di fare
in modo di vivere la fine contenuta
nell'inizio è strabiliante questo
pensiero
eppure che cosa è il navigatore se non
la rappresentazione di questo che cosa
accade quando voi dovete andare in un
posto e mettetela destinazio
viene fuori tutto il tragitto
quindi che cosa avete rappresentata e
che non mi crea ansia la fine dove
dovete andare contenuta dall'inizio
un'altra dimostrazione
l'atto di pensiero quando voi parlate
si spera che abbiate già presente dove
volete arrivare
e quindi che cosa dovrete fare solo
dipanare nel tempo quel pensiero che ha
gia alla fine contenuta dentro di voi è
la potenzialità che c'è nel seme che
aspetta solo attraverso un tragitto di
arrivare alla fine e questo come si
caratterizza nella nostra esistenza si
caratterizza dal fatto che le strutture
narrative ci arrivino quando sentiamo
raccontare una storia siamo
assolutamente coinvolti perché perché
sappiamo che cercherà di rispondere a
tre domande fondamentali che sono quelle
che un brano di musica rappresenta
pienamente per questo vi dico
riappropriatevi della vostra capacità di
essere musicisti perché tutti noi
abbiamo questa capacità che cosa fa
brano di musica inizia articolando
arriverà un punto culminante ed a quel
punto culminante andrà a finire questo
caratterizza qualunque struttura
narrativa e quello che oggi si tenta di
insegnare ai bambini quando devono
svolgere un tema gli si dice prova a
immaginare una struttura dovrà esporre
quello che accade
pensate che c'è una forma musicale che
si chiama forma sonata che è
caratterizzata da esposizione
poi dovrei sviluppare le idee che hai
messo in campo nell'esposizione in
musica si dice esposizione sviluppo e
poi dovrei andare a concludere ripresa
caspita ma allora i musicisti ci possono
dare una mano straordinaria comprendere
come siamo fatti ma noi quali
prerequisiti abbiamo allora pensate in
quel kit famoso che abbiamo ricevuto
abbiamo per esempio le dinamiche che poi
l'uomo ha trasposto in questo
straordinario mezzo di comunicazione che
il suolo per esempio un rumore
fortissimo ci mette in grande ansia
perché si scatena dentro di noi una
enorme tempesta adrenalinica perché
dobbiamo essere pronti a fuggire
oppure restare nelle mobilità per
comprendere che cosa dobbiamo fare nella
situazione allora che cos'è in musica il
fortissimo quando un brano raggiunge il
parossismo questo ha dentro di noi una
corrispondenza poi c'è la relazione fra
i suoni perché questa è la cosa
fondamentale la grande conclusione del
nostro tempo quale pensare che il suono
sia da musica non è così il suono sono
solo vibrazioni regolari di corpi
elastici che cos'è che fa trasformare il
suono in musica la coscienza
allora questo pensate che straordinario
pensiero è per tutti coloro che pensano
che la musica stia morendo sia morta
finché ci sarà un essere umano che è la
musica la musica non potrà morire ma ci
vogliono persone che vi portino a
riacquisire questa consapevolezza
io dico sempre che ho un atteggiamento
socratico invece che pensare il portale
qualcuno ha qualche cosa come un vaso
vuoto che viene riempito da un vaso
pieno che mi trasferisce le informazioni
preferisco per questo bacino di utenza
che ci caratterizza da circa duemila
anni dare più credito all'espressione
vinose santon nasce the two conosci te
stesso come direi già tutto dentro
tirano fuori i socrate con la sua arte
magnetica ci aiuta a fare proprio questo
e ci vogliono degli operatori sul campo
però ci vogliono delle levatrici che ci
aiutino ad acquisire questa
consapevolezza
adesso proviamo a fare insieme un
esperimento alzatevi in piedi per un
attimo per favore
e provate a rappresentare gestualmente
questi due suoni mi sembra più consono
fare una cosa di questo tipo
dai gesti che ho visto fare mi sembra
che forse ha delle reti di più
acquistata la pala che accomodante
6 luglio 1789 danton mara robespierre
dicano allora ragazzi e c'è un po di
anche per quanti fissate per il 14
siamo messi uno dei tre ha un'intuizione
le disse ragazzi smuoveremo un sacco di
gente ma non abbiamo un inno è qui
bisogna mettere in piedi un audizione i
musicisti sono molto soggetti a questo
ci fa un audizione to presente in quel
materiale
generalmente c'è una commissione che poi
dice va bene grazie si accomodi le
faremo sapere
e che cos'è accaduto hanno fatto si sono
presentati vari 1 affatto così loro
hanno ascoltato e non ha detto sì
oddio potrebbe essere interessante prego
le faremo sapere certo abbiamo un po di
fretta
poi è arrivato un altro ha fatto così
bene questo era un pochino meglio se ne
sono avvicendate varie pensare al
pianoforte nel 1789 e dura ma comunque
va bene lo stesso e poi è arrivato uno
vi ha fatto così
ah ma allora c'è qualcosa che ci
caratterizza davvero noi abbiamo
istintivamente il senso della
estroversione vuol dire qualche cosa che
dal soggetto parte e si proietta verso
l'esterno
quando mettiamo in campo questo
intervallo che è quello fondante della
musica è l'unico dato tecnico che vi
voglio lasciare l'intervallo dipinta
vuol dire la distanza che separa il
primo suono dal secondo questo
quindi scarnificando questo tema da
tutte le notizie che ci stanno intorno
c'è un metodo inventato da un giapponese
per portare la musica i bambini molti
dei vostri figli probabilmente avranno
preso contatto con questo il metodo
suzuki è uno dei brani caratterizzanti e
questo
qui accaduto anche un fatto molto
importante quella struttura narrativa
che ha un momento di proposta di
apertura poi deve trovare la sua
naturale compensazione sarebbe stato
terribile avere una cosa di questo tipo
va bene a questa è una cosa per addetti
ai lavori e un tema molto complesso che
sicuramente su dei bambini non avrà
invece come appaga la nostra necessità
di struttura narrativa qualche cosa che
sia fra che raggiunga un punto culminate
e da quello torni indietro allora che
cosa cerco di lasciarvi oggi come
messaggio noi siamo la musica
riappropriamoci di questo pensate al
tempo di esecuzione di un brano come noi
riusciamo a capirlo istintivamente
perché perché abbiamo il ritmo dentro
abbiamo costantemente il cuore che batte
che ci dà una pulsazione abbiamo i
nostri passi che sono binari uno di
appoggio di rilassamento
infatti come critica un concerto che
cosa succede che è raro trovare qualcuno
che ascoltando una esecuzione di ca
certo questa sera alla modulazione al ii
circolo delle quinte non è stata ben
soddisfatta devo dire che anche le
melodie nella loro relazione
no quello che generalmente viene detto e
io non è che me ne intendo sbagliato
però mi sembra che non andavano insieme
e poi c'è un'altra cosa importantissima
la metrica che all'interno di un
discorso deve venire fuori la metrica
che
un discorso di reni fuori la mitica che
all'interno di un discorso deve venire
fuori la metrica che all'interno di un
discorso
noi facciamo musica costantemente
riappropriatevi di questa capacità
perché ciascuno di noi è portatore di
musica bisogna riappropriarsi di questa
enorme risorsa che ognuno di noi dei
grazie